he's my best friend Demi lavato says age  could have kept her and a 35 year old  boyfriend Wilmer Valderrama apart she  recently posted you celebrated six years  together with Wilmer and everyone thinks  it's over six year anniversary we met  six years ago but yeah I knew I loved  him when I met him so he had some he had  some hesitations once I got older it was  Tim we could be together  yeah anyways um he's my best friend  the pair has been together for years and  December the 23 year old dish on whether  her man was planning a proposal this  year some of your fans seemed to thank  you and Wilmer are secretly married is  that true pal we're definitely not  secretly tricking toots 2016 be a  potential engagement year for you you  gotta ask him I have no idea